hey youtubers is Charlie you guys have
been messaging me to do a video for the
big plot hold spider-man homecoming it's
so big you could fly the Hulkbuster
through it so just careful for spoilers
from the movie if you haven't seen it
yet I'm still doing the movie ticket
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video but all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so the timeline everybody is
freaking out about that title card that
says eight years later in homecoming is
confirmed I'll explain how the dates all
work out to be taking place during 2017
meaning that the Avengers would have to
take place in 2010 a common-sense
marketing materials in relief states
state that the Battle of New York and
the Avengers movie took place during
2012 meaning that this would only be six
years later because they're cleaning up
debris from the end of the battle so
everybody's like wTF is going on that
doesn't make any sense
Kevin Feige sat in the editing Bay
himself to supervise part of this like
he saw this and approved it for release
it's being seen this way all over the
world so if there was an error they
would have put a hard stop on it just
edited that little bit and then thrown
it back out a while before everybody
started seeing it and commenting on this
most people came out of this asking me
does this movie take place in 2020
because they're just dating it from the
2012 Battle of New York but there are a
couple moments during the film that
place it during 2017 the biggest one
being when spider-man is looking at the
shield dossier on Aaron Davis the
Prowler it says that he's 33 years old
and he was born in 1984 meaning this
film is taking place during 2017 so
assuming the Kevin Feige meant it to be
this way for take place eight years
after the Battle of New York you have to
reevaluate all the previous movies and
when they're happening so the first big
takeaway is that what Marvel is saying
is is that you don't go by movie's
release date for when the movies take
place so for instance phase 1 you have
Iron Man in Incredible Hulk in 2008 then
Iron Man 2 in 2010 Thor and Captain
America in 2011 then the Avengers in
2012 where they're basically saying is
that those movies didn't take place
years after each other they're
compressing time and saying say like the
events of Iron Man 2 Thor Captain
America all took place during real
typically the same time period with the
exception of most of Captain America
because like 99% of that film took place
during World War two with like the last
couple minutes taking place in present
day but then you say hey wait a minute
there's some Netflix defenders marketing
material New York bulletin that's the
newspaper that shows up during the
defenders series and it's dated
Saturday May 5th 2012 meaning that like
right after this movie came out the
newspaper ran this big story buildings
level hundreds kills in midtown battle
what's probably happening is Kevin Feige
is saying the movies have their own time
line everybody else that does things for
the TV shows isn't really in on our
narrative so this piece of marketing
wasn't made this year this was made
years ago before they ever knew that
Spiderman was going to be in the
universe in Kevin Feige decided that he
wanted spider-man to be eight years out
from the Battle of New York so it's kind
of a George Lucas thing where you have
the person up at the top
changing cannon just a little bit it's
sort of breaking preexisting cannon but
because he's the person at the top that
controls everything he's the one that
decides what's canon what's not canon
so yes the film does break the pre
spiderman timeline before he entered the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but they're
sort of editing things so that it makes
a little bit more sense based on his age
because if they would have gone with the
original timeline he would have been a
senior 18 19 years old he would have
been spider-man for much longer he would
have landed on their radar much sooner
and it wouldn't have made sense why Tony
waited this long to go find him so Sony
falls on hard times decides that Marvel
knows what they're doing they can
actually make a pretty badass spider-man
movie let's share the character they
work out an arrangement then they decide
hey we should make spider-man be a kid
in this movie that's the beginning of
timeline problems but Kevin Feige says
you know what there'll be people that
will bug us about this but as long as
the movies make sense let's not worry
about it
so you have even the Star Wars people
people ask about Star Wars Canon all the
time things don't always make sense when
Disney bought the property they
completely throughout the expanded
universe all the Star Wars novels that
people have been reading since the 90s
so Marvel is kind of doing the same
thing but it's still better than James
Bond continuity the Bond films have some
of the worst continuity
because you've had so many different
actors play bond it just doesn't always
quite work out you have new
screenwriters come in and say okay let's
tell a really cool Bond story but we're
not going to worry about every last
little detail in the previous movies so
spider-man homecoming is just a signal
that this will probably happen in future
films but they do try really hard they
have teams of people that work to make
sure everything makes sense but if you
remember a couple years ago they
actually had a creative committee that
helped them oversee the first couple of
phases worth of films when there were
problems like this there would be
somebody that would say hey you know
eight years later that doesn't make
sense because the Avengers took place
during 2012 and this isn't 2020 this is
2017 they kind of got rid of that group
of people and now what they're saying is
is that the phase one movies in the
Phase two movies were kind of squashed
together in the timeline so a lot of
those movies we're taking place during
the same week of the year instead of
them happening one right after the other
so the best version of the timeline we
have right now is is that Iron Man 1
takes place in 2008 Iron Man 2
Incredible Hulk in Thor all take place
during 2009 then that next year the
avengers takes place in 2010 Iron Man 3
takes place 2013-2014 Thor the dark
world
Captain America Winter Soldier guardians
of the galaxy and then guardians of the
galaxy - all take place relatively in
the same amount of time now remember
James Gunn said the guardians 2 takes
place a couple months after the end of
guardians 1 so you get an idea for how
you can't go by release dates anymore
but then you have 2015 Avengers age of
Ultron and ant-man 2016 Doctor Strange
takes place and then now 2017
Captain America Civil War couple months
before spider-man homecoming and then
obviously homecoming so you just have a
bunch of different movies all taking
place during the same year whereas
previously people would just go buy
movie release dates so you think the
events of the phase 1 phase 2 movies
were taking place much further apart
than they were before that's the
simplest way I could think to explain it
and it might sound kind of funny but
it's all do all of these problems are
just due to the fact that they want
Peter Parker to be 1516 when this movie
picks up let me know in the comments
though what was your reaction
when you saw that title card eight years
later did you get confused did you not
think about it I saw the movie a couple
times so obviously the second time I saw
it I was thinking about it more the
first time I saw it I didn't think about
it quite as much but just don't be
surprised there'll be a couple more
continuity errors that pop up here and
there during the Marvel movies even
though they do pay attention to
continuity but what's going to happen
next is is I'll post some Easter eggs
there's arrow season six they've already
started teasing Deathstroke coming back
there's a bunch of big characters so
I'll try to post those videos as fast as
possible but leave all your requests in
the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner melissa Kelly please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
spider-man Easter eggs and you can click
here for brand new flash season 4 thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight